well it is the hot spot in town
serving elevated food and astounding
cocktails and now
a night for all of you wine lovers we
are talking about cassie beach house
at virgin hotels las vegas and joining
me is the general manager
jason martucci let's talk about the
restaurant we were just talking off the
air
it is absolutely gorgeous inside tell us
about the fair
and and the ambiance so it's uh coastal
italian
cuisine uh we're part of the wish you
were here group
you may know some of our properties in
la as well
yeah close to italian we have great
house-made pastas we make our own dough
for our pizzas
fresh whole fish really is great and now
you're
doing a special wine night so we're
going to get a little uh
a little lesson from you here talk about
the wine night that you're doing it's on
mondays what's it called
so it's called viva vino okay from
4 pm until we close monday night half
price bottles of wine
for all locals so whether it's uh the
big boy over here camis or sassaka or
sasukaya
or any of our high-end french wines
everything is is half off
half off now we've got a nice rose here
let's talk about
first of all i was just swirling like i
knew what i was doing even though i have
no idea what i'm doing
tell us why why we swirl the two main
reasons
uh one is really to aerate the wine okay
so you allow the air to get in there so
you can
get a good smell and aroma what am i get
looking for here
so for this you're going to have some
some light fruit
uh so a little bit of berries a little
bit of crisp apple in there as well
a little citrus smell that a little
little bit of citrus uh fleur de mer
rose french off the french coast
really is known to be drank young
vibrant
fruit forward citrus forward something
that you can enjoy on a hot day
cheers let's give it a taste uh it's
definitely a hot day today
and this is uh this is we're actually
pouring we have bottomless
rose every day for brunch and this is
one of our
options truly is rose all day let me ask
you a quick question i know we only have
a few seconds left but
with the the whites and the and the
roses those are things that you want to
drink young you mentioned that
you don't want those sitting around very
long for them for the most part jose's
yes for the most part whites yes there's
a couple of white wines that you
let age but for the most part yeah
everything is meant to be drinking young
well i know we don't don't want to just
talk about vitavino i hear it's a
special day for someone
it is my uh my daughter sloan is turning
11 today so happy birthday
cheers to sloane happy birthday and if
you want to check out vidavino it's a
weekly event mondays from 4pm
and they offer those locals 50 off all
bottles of wine definitely want to check
it out
las vegas now we'll be right back